[Music]
all kinds of modern amazing things were
happening at the beginning of the 20th
century especially in the United States
of America and and the movies and
Hollywood were one of those things that
we kind of I think have lost track of
how what a quantum shift watching movies
represented for the experience of life
sure there have been actors in plays
before but the first of all the the the
glut of entertainment that suddenly
existed and the almost phantasmagorical
quality of watching real people moving
around that we're in front of you but in
some netherworld and film and they were
really in London or India or or the
Yukon or whatever the the and and and
time was suddenly change that went from
childhood to adulthood
everything about the cinema was we have
to understand what a huge change that
was and how how mutable it seemed to
make reality so you take that that the
fact of cinema TV video everything we
now for five generations have taken as
the way things are so that I think that
gave us gave us and especially Americans
obviously French people and English
people as well but this this idea that
that reality was mutable then on top of
that and with that you have this this
celebrity culture where where celebrity
itself is there are my orders of
magnitude suddenly more celebrities but
there were you know in the 19th century
and earlier there were there were famous
people but a few of them and and and and
and and now there were hundreds and then
eventually thousands of famous people
who were now famous for pretending to be
somebody else actors that was a strange
new condition and and so for a long time
for much of the 20th century
people looked up to two movie stars
because they seem to have real potency
in this world where individuals seem
more and more part of the mass here here
were the people because they were famous
and because we watched them and stared
at them and dreamed about them were the
the were like superheroes or demigods so
by the end of the 20th century or before
the end of the 20th century who wouldn't
if you're an American
steeped in this movie and then
television culture I want to be famous
maybe there's no reason for you to be
famous but my god only famous people
have real agency in the world
so we got to that where where Fame is
its own end um you also again there's
advertising everywhere but advertising
in the advertising industry we're really
an American invention starting way back
in the 1800s when when for instance the
political candidate presidential
candidate William Henry Harrison was the
first marketed advertised presidential
candidate he he was this this rich guy
who they wanted to rebrand as a humble
guy who'd grown up in a log cabin so log
cabins became his his his icon his his
brand being symbol and they made real
big ones and little ones and and liquor
and and and and facial creams in in log
cabin containers and they made chants
and songs and he won by a landslide over
a guy who was actually of humble origins
so advertising as part of this fantasy
industrial complex that is so American
and so defining of America has has
become has been a big part of what we're
talking about as well Disneyland
I love Disneyland but but it it became
when it was created in the 1950s not
just as a little amusement park to to
promote Walt Disney's animated films but
as this other version of reality that
was more that was real in the it was
there you could go there and buy things
that these old fashioned
cops on Main Street USA with actors but
they were selling you stuff what's what
happened in Disneyland starting in 1955
did not stay there and that Main Street
USA most of all became a kind of model
for how you build shopping centers how
you build suburbs how you theme
everything from restaurants to hotels to
- to shops to clubs so the the Hollywood
idea and and what came before in pop
culture and what came after and and as
it expanded to sort of subsume all of
American life is is is a is a big part
of how we as Americans have become so
iffy about telling what's fake from
what's real what's true from what's
false
[Music]